بينما تلاحقه اتهامات بالتجسس من دول
غربيه يواجه التطبيق الصيني تيك توك هذه
الاتهامات باطلاق خدمات جديده تحمل مزايا
مختلفه مثل فلتر بولد غلامور وخدمه سيريز
التي اتاحت لصناع المحتوى نشر مقاطع مصوره
تصل مده كل منها الى 20 دقيقه ليفتح
التطبيق الصيني ملامح منافسه شرسه امام
تطبيقات مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى
كفيسبوك وانستجرام وحتى يوتيوب
الخدمات الجديده المعلنه لتيك توك اثارت
نوعا من التساؤلات لدى المستخدمين ازاء
قدره هذه المؤثرات الخاصه المطوره عبر
الذكاء الاصطناعي على تجميل وجوههم
لتعاود الجدل بعيدا عن تهم التجسس والحديث
عن معايير الجمال التي تسوق لها شبكات
الاجتماعي خبراء التجميل يقولون ان هذا
النوع من الفلاتر يعد احدث الهجمه لاسطوره
الجمال المثالي مما يجعل مستخدمي هذا
النوع من الفلاتر ينشطون الى استخدام
الحميات المفرطه وينقص الثقه بالنفس لديهم
تطبيق تيك توك الذي بلغ عدد مستخدمه مليار
مستخدم نشط شهريا خلال شهر سبتمبر 20 21
يعتبر في الولايات المتحده تهديدا للامن
القومي من جانب مسؤولين ومحليين كثيرين
يتهمون التطبيق بنقل معلومات عن
المستخدمين لبكين وهو ما تنفيه الشركه